مجلس السياده يرفض التفاوض مع حميه قبل
تسليمه
توتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بعد وفاه
الاسير خضر عدنان
وزير العدل العراقي يجيب عن سؤال اين قاتل
الهاشمي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم القناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من السودان حيث افاد مراسل العربيه
بتجدد الاشتباكات في مناطق عده بالعاصمه
الخرطوم رغم اعلان تجديد الهدنه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وبالتزامن مع ذلك قال عضو
مجلس السياده السوداني والفريق ياسر عطا
للعربيه انه لا تفاوض مع المتمردين في
اشاره الى قوات الدعم السريع وقائدها الا
بعد تسليم حميدتين للعداله مشيرا الى انها
تمرضت على الدوله وراحت تنهب مقدرات
البلاد كما اكد ان الاولويه هي لحسم
المعركه وان اي وساطه سياسيه لن تنجح في
الوقت الحالي
بعد اضراب استمر لمده 86 يوما توفي الاسير
الفلسطيني خضره عدنان داخل احد السجون
الاسرائيليه فيما حمل نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني السلطات الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه
وفاته ووصفها بعمليه اغتيال ممنهجات وعاقب
الاعلان عن وفاته اطلقت فصائل فلسطينيه من
قطاع غزه رشقات صاروخيه باتجاه مستوطنات
جنوب اسرائيل فيما قصفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه اهدافا شرط مدينه غزه وافادت
معلومات بان الجيش اصدر اوامر للمستوطنين
في غلاف غزه بالبقاء قرب الملاجئ
الى العراق هذه المره وبعد تداول انباء عن
اختفاء قاتل الخبير السياسي العراقي شامل
الهاشمي شدد وزير العدل خالد شواني على ان
الفاعل موجود لدى دوائر التحقيقيه وليس في
السجون وزارته الوزير اوضح في المقابله مع
العربيه ان القاتله لم يكتسب الدرجه
القطعيه في الحكم ليرسل الى سجون الوزاره
مرجعا السبب الى وجود عدد كبير من النزلاء
في دوائر الاصلاح ما اجبر الدوله على
تعاقد مع شركات في القطاع الخاص
بعيدا عن عالم السياسه كشف الدراسه اجراها
علماء امريكيون عن ما يحدث داخل مخ
الانسان قبل لحظات من الموت مؤكدين وجود
نشاط دمغي شبيه بالوعي لدى الذين يحتضرون
الدراسه تقول ان التجارب اجريت لاربعه
مرضى ماتوا في المستشفى اثناء مراقبه
ادمغتهم باستخدام تسجيل بيانات التخطيط
كهربيه الدماغ مضيفه انه وفي لحظات
الاحتضار اظهرت اثنان من المرضى زياده في
معدل ضربات القلب الى جانب زياده نشاط
موجه جاما والتي تعتبر اسرع نشاطا للدماغ
ومرتبطه بالوعي
في خبرنا الاخير استقل الاب الروحي للذكاء
الاصطناعي دكتور جيفري هنتون من شركه جوجل
بسبب مخاوفهم من مخاطر التكنولوجيا التي
ساهم هو نفسه في تطويرها هل تنكد ان
الدردشه التي تستخدم في تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي مخيفه جدا محذره من انها ستصبح
اكثر ذكاء من البشر ويمكن استغلالها من
قبل الجهات السيئه كما اعرب هنتر عن اسفه
واعتذاره لمساهمته بوصول الذكاء الاصطناعي
لهذه الدرجه من التطور المخيف على حد وصفه